well last night was our first show of
the year so we decided take a minute to
talk about the biggest issue facing this
country going forward no it's not higher
GDP growth despite what some think-tank
people will tell you it's not definitely
not some obscure middle-eastern hellhole
our leaders claim we should be policing
forever it's not even illegal
immigration as big a problem as that is
and as much time as we have spent
talking about it the real problem is
families America used to be the best
country in the world for families
Americans could get married and afford
to raise their own children if your kids
worked hard you could expect they'd be a
little more successful maybe than you
were that was called the American dream
and for a small group of affluent people
it still exists they're still living
like it's 1965 and good for them but for
everyone else that dream is dying
America's middle class is in decline
because middle-class American families
are declining so the question is why is
that happening well there are a lot of
reasons it's happening but a major
driver of family collapse the one that
nobody ever talks about for some reason
is simple economics and we explained it
last night
study after study has shown that when
men make less than women women generally
don't want to marry them now maybe they
should want to marry them but they don't
over big populations this causes a drop
in marriage a spike and out of wedlock
births and all the familiar disasters
that inevitably follow more drug and
alcohol abuse higher incarceration rates
fewer families form to the next
generation now let's be clear about that
statement first of all it is factually
true and that's the essential test of
anything that's the test that we go by
in 2015 a study by the decidedly non
conservative Brookings Institution found
that falling male wages caused about a
quarter of the decline in marriage rates
over the past thirty five years two
years later MIT researchers found that
when factories closed marriage rates go
down and single parenthood becomes more
common that as you could guess causes a
higher proportion of children to wind up
on drugs or in prison so it's not a
small thing and by the way many other
studies have reached the same
conclusions over long periods of time
this is real so what we said is a
statement of fact we would
weren't in an ideal world none of this
would matter the marriage rate never
would have declined when manufacturing
died and everything in Middle America
would be fine but it's not and we're not
in charge of that all we can do is tell
the truth about what happened which we
did because it actually matters and that
turned out to be too much for the people
who believe it's their job to prevent
you from knowing why your country is
going down the tubes those people got
very angry here's a selection it reminds
me of when they blamed one women for
pregnancy as if he had nothing to do
with it this idea that you know to keep
women down that's going on I don't know
it looked like Looney Tom to me yeah
Newtown notice that no one no contested
the facts of what we said in fact later
in this show one of those same hosts
admitted that in fact women do strongly
prefer marrying men who make more than
they do so it's true but it's not on the
list of approved talking points so it
can't ever be said out loud those are
the rules and anyone who violates those
rules must be punished this is very
common and if you're wondering how we
wound up in the Dark Age we're currently
living through this is how we did this
is why important science is no longer
being conducted this is why art isn't
being made this is why comedy is dying
it's why people aren't thinking for
themselves anymore which means the end
of creativity it's why the rest of us
stand by like cowards as the innocent
are punished for crimes they didn't
commit
because we're all terrified we're
terrified of being denounced by some
mindless ideologue on TV or shamed and
ostracized on social media for stepping
out of line or silenced completely by
some big tech firm a mob of angry
children is suddenly in charge of the
country these are people seeking a
revolution they're fighting for the
status quo to protect their own status
they are drunk on power and they're
looking for new people to hurt someday
we're going to look back on this moment
with shame and horror but in the
meantime we should remember that terror
only works if we play along with it so
what if we decided not to what if all of
us decided to tell
the truth about something every day in
public what would happen then what could
they do about it
they can't punish everybody we're the
majority let's try that we're starting
tonight with Heather McDonald she's a
fearless person a fellow at the
Manhattan Institute and the author of
the book the diversity of delusion how
race and gender pandering corrupt
University and undermine our culture and
she joins us Heather thanks very much
for coming on so my theory is that when
you say the true things people get
outraged so you know hurt dog barks but
just to be clear as a social scientists
yourself I hope you'll confirm for
audience that this is not a
controversial statement that male
employment and wages directly affect the
marriage rate do they not well first of
all Tucker I want to commend you for
making the breakdown of marriage a
central focus of your show there's no
bigger social catastrophe of our age
than the fact that more and more
children are being raised without their
fathers and the elites understand that
marriage has not disappeared from the
elites that's for sure and yet they are
absolutely unwilling to send the message
that fathers are as important to their
children as mothers their tongues are
tied they refuse to say it it's one of
those truths that again is being
completely denied by elite culture why
because it violates the feminist Nostrum
that strong women could do it all
now you're right that there's an
economic component to this and most
famously William Julius Wilson explained
the drop in marriage among the black
community as a result of jobs leaving
the Midwest and he said that the male
unemployment decreases females
willingness to marry but I think you
also have to look at a culture
explanation because I remember being
taken around in a ride-along by a
Chicago cop a very handsome man solid
job good pension to look forward to he
had fathered several children out of
wedlock why because the marriage norm
had simply disappeared from the black
community so I think this is
a cultural matter as well it's a product
to a certain extent of the feminist
attack on males we are living through a
period where males are being constantly
disparaged as simply the source of evil
in our world and they are responding
tragically by withdrawing from
competition taking their marbles and
going home and that is leaving us all at
greater risk and in some cases taking
their own lives I would say I mean the
suicide rate for American men is higher
that it's been in a long time I would
just note that the problems that William
Julius Wilson chronicled I thought so
well 30 or 40 years ago are now the
problems of rural America which
obviously has a completely different
racial demographic and political beliefs
than inner-city America and it seems to
me that when it happens to two different
groups the very same thing that would be
the wake-up call for our policymakers to
say wait a second maybe we should get
involved in thinking about how to fix
this considering in our neighborhoods
where rich people live in my
neighborhood for example there are no
single mothers everyone's married
because it works so why aren't they
doing their best to pass on the thing
that is working for them it just seems
grotesque to me no I think we do have to
look at Industrial Policy and make sure
that there are good well-paying jobs
there I just wouldn't assume that that
is going to be enough at this point
right to turn around the culture again
we need to valorize males and and the
culture needs to say males are not toxic
masculinity is not toxic there are male
virtues of valor courage chivalry
heroism and war that are really uniquely
male they should not be disparaged
females have complementary virtues and
values that are also essential to
children so wait guys what where does
the idea come from that when men fail
women win I mean that really is the
underlying assumption of like the dumb
people we always play from other shows
you know men are declining this is
great for us but men and women are
totally interconnected so how can the
failure of one help the other doesn't
hurt all of us yeah it's a preposterous
zero-sum mentality but there's a lot of
females who are angry angry for no
reason at all they have an axe on theirs
to grind a chip on their shoulder and
they're constantly looking for ways to
feel offended mostly by dredging up
sexism from the past because it's almost
impossible to find today I mean you have
females that are excelling in education
there's not a single mainstream
institution that is not twisting itself
into knots to hire and promote as many
females as possible and yet females are
still ringing their hands over the
alleged sexism of the 50s simply so they
can feel like they're victims
preposterous I am NOT a victim I don't
know any female victims frankly but but
there is a sense that in order for
females to succeed it has to be at the
expense of males and through a constant
D valorisation that does masculinity it
doesn't work we we don't win when some
of us lose I don't believe that it's not
true Heather thank you very much thank
you